a young right-hander in zach gallon who
is making his third start of the season
for the arizona diamondbacks new jersey
native just 25 years of age another 2-2
and he went around for strike three
george springer goes down to start the
night
and he waves and misses on that breaking
ball
another strikeout to start for zach
galen he's gotten a lot of swings and
misses on that fastball
in his young mlb career
goes to the fastball and freezes bregman
at the knees zach allen strikes out the
side brandon bilac in his first career
major league start first one to marte
and he attacks and sends one into left
center field for a base hit top ten in
the big leagues in the first two weeks
of the season and on base percentage he
is aboard with the two out singer 2-2
on the ground to the left side
on the run good throw by bregman to end
the inning bradley back in the lineup
after not playing the last couple of
games was dealing with a quad injury
shoots it the other way good take on the
infield and in time eduardo escobar
manning the left side one of the best
third base defenders in all the baseball
brant league retired to start the second
two men out in the base runner
nice pitch
gets the strikeout zach gallon he has
spanned four and the diamondbacks have a
one out base runner for carson kellett
peralta with the lead off first and the
breaking ball is grounded left side
correa to his left he has the second for
one altuve on the first and that's a six
four three double play to end the inning
springer struck out looking in his first
advantage to start the ball
game gets him to roll over and off speed
delivery a double play ball and indeed
the diamondbacks turn two ahmed to marty
to walker they're in business here candy
two on and one out for calhoun in the
third change up strike three bilat gets
calhoun and picks up his first strikeout
on a beautiful change of pace and
there's two out
on the ground weekly hit
correa with the play
so belak works out of trouble and jams
martay altuve over to third base so two
outs now for guriel there's a ground
ball of the left side hits the bag and
goes into left field for a base hit a
break for the astros and it's an rbi
take him any way you can get him so one
nothing houston that brings up carlos
correa how to hit his first step up
walker off the back this time for a 3-2
with the runner going and correa leaning
out ends up striking out
one out down that brings up escobar
popped to short first time up escobar
sends one towards left center field on
the move there's springer for the out
they'll send up andy young nick ahmed
and then around at the top of the order
could tell martin
young muscles one into center field
springer coming on and he held out for
the outs robs young of a base hit
springer has been playing an excellent
center field tonight nothing unusual
about that one out going on for jose
altuve who's one for two gallon the kick
and the 1-0 and that is drilled deep to
left field sending back peralta looking
up see you later
jose altuve goes deep for the third time
this year and the astros lead is two to
nothing so for only the second time
tonight the diabetes have a runner in
scoring position
there's a fly ball center field pretty
well again springer goes back this one's
going to be up off the wall extra bases
nobody's called it yet i guess it's in
play it'll be a double 2-1 as marta
scores from second and they have the
tying run at third and the go ahead run
at first base with one out on the ground
right side and through this game is tied
at two david peralta comes up here in
the six to make it a 2-2 game 1-2
bouncing ball right side altuve over
throws to second and a run will score to
give the diamondbacks a 3-2 lead one-two
paints the outside corner for called
strike three and taylor gets out of it
that brings up cole calhoun cajuno for
three
calhoun on the ground altuve from his
knees to correa sidearm to first in time
oh
what a double play turn by this veteran
group altuve correa guriel and the bases
are wiped clean
the athleticism of correa is i mean
face christian walker and he swings away
at the first pitch
bregman has it and andre scrub with one
pitch and one out
now brightman he'll step in with the
time run at second he's a go ahead run
to the plate and bregman hits it in the
air pretty deep to left field it sends
back peralta still going back looking up
see you later
a go-ahead two-run home run for alex
breckman and the astros are back on top
four to three
bases loaded for cole calhoun and the
2-2 pitch and a drive to right field
down the line and that is a fair ball
here comes a winning run lo castro
scores right behind him as ahmed and the
diamondbacks have walked off the astros
they come from behind and win it five to
four